hi und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid
wir sprechen heute ein bisschen früher
als sonst über die erdefender 23 das ist
eine internationale luftwaffenübung
unter deutscher Führung die heute
gestartet ist mit dabei sind 25 Staaten
und die meisten davon sind Teil der NATO
ja und in den nächsten zwei Wochen
werden Kampfjets Transport und
Tankflugzeuge über Deutschlandreisen
10.000 Soldaten mit 250 Flugzeugen
nehmen an der Übung teil darunter 70
Militärmaschine aus Deutschland ein
vergleichbares luftwaffenmanöver über
Deutschland gab es bisher noch nicht er
Defender ist damit die größte verlege
Übung von Luftstreitkräften seitdem
Bestehen der NATO ja und der Plan ist um
bestmöglich auf den Ernstfall
vorbereitet zu sein sollen die Piloten
eben in einem Gebiet üben indem sie auch
im realen Krisenfall eingesetzt werden
würden die Idee für die gab es aber
schon vor fünf Jahren also nach der
Eroberung der Krim durch Russland aber
lange vor Beginn des großflächigen
angriffskriegs auf die Ukraine über den
wir ja hier auch oft sprechen trainiert
wird da gerade also der
nato-bündnisfall der dann eintritt wenn
ein Mitgliedstaat angegriffen wird und
simuliert wird bei dieser bei dieser
Übung jetzt ein Angriff auf die
Großstadt Rostock aus dem Osten ja wir
fragen uns heute wie läuft diese große
Übung an warum wird sie gerade jetzt
durchgeführt und wie steht es so
eigentlich um die
luftverteidigungsfähigkeit der NATO und
dazu spreche ich mit verschiedenen
Leuten ich spreche mit dem ZDF Reporter
Fabian Köhler der uns live vom
Fliegerhorst Wunstorf zugeschaltet ist
ich spreche mit dem Inspektor der
deutschen Luftwaffe general Leutnant
Ingo Gerhard und ich spreche mit ZDF
Korrespondent Florian neuhahn in Brüssel
und wie immer spreche ich nicht nur mit
denen sondern auch mit euch habt ihr
Fragen zu diesem Thema oder wollt eure
Meinung mit uns teilen dann tut das
gerne wie immer hier bei euch im Youtube
Chat oder an die Mailadresse die ihr
gerade im Bild eingeblendet seht und ja
was heute schon alles passiert ist am
ersten Tag dieser großen üben äh das
Übung das bespreche ich jetzt erstmal
mit Fabian Köhler der uns hier live
zugeschaltet ist hallo Fabian
hallo ich grüße Euch
Fabian du stehst da jetzt gerade in
Niedersachsen in Wunstorf wie erlebst du
den Staat dieser riesigen Erde Fender
Übung heute
ja also wir sind ja hier in Wunstorf in
aller Frühe schon angereist heute Morgen
die Sonne ging im Grunde genommen gerade
auf weil wir schon fürs ZDF
Morgenmagazin von hier ausgeschaltet
haben und dann startete der Tag relativ
langsam und ganz entspannt die erste
Maschine ist so gegen 8 Uhr oder kurz
nach 8 Uhr hier von Wunstorf abgehoben
das ist ja so etwas wie die Logistik
Drehscheibe generell ist es die Logistik
Drehscheibe es ist das
lufttransportgeschader 62 welches hier
in Wunstorf stationiert ist und es ist
auch die Logistik Drehscheibe für eher
Defender 23 das heißt hier sind die
großen Maschinen der Luftwaffe
stationiert das sind die Airbus a300m
A400M Entschuldigung und mittlerweile
sind auch Amerikaner hier und auch ein
rumänisches Flugzeug und von hier aus
wird jetzt Material werden auch Personen
in die verschiedenen Einsatzgebiete
geflogen und das ganze logistische
gesteuert
die muss man sich das denn vorstellen
was passiert da logistisch ich glaube
wunststoff ist ja auch relativ wichtig
zum tanken oder
genau hier in Wunstorf hat man in den
letzten Wochen ein großes mobiles
Tanklager eingerichtet wir hatten eben
auch im Rahmen der Pressetour die heute
hier stattfindet die Gelegenheit uns
dieses Tanklager anzugucken dort sind ja
muss man sich vorstellen wie große
Trampoline die sind schwarz drin ist
natürlich Flug Benzin rundherum sind so
Weller aufgeschüttet und das ist ein
mobiles Tanklager was insgesamt ungefähr
2,4 Millionen Liter Flug Benzin fast man
muss ungefähr wissen pro Tag benötigt
man für diese Übung eher Defender 23 und
400 bis 500 000 Liter pro Tag und das
will man halt eben hier auch in Wunstorf
sicherstellen dass alle Flugzeuge mit
Treibstoff versorgt werden können es
hieß sie eben vom
Generalinspektor der Luftwaffe Ingo
Gerhard das ohne wunststoff wäre es im
Grunde genommen gar nicht möglich
gewesen diese große Übung diese
großflächige Übung eher Defender 23 ins
Leben zu rufen also es ist schon ein
sehr wichtiger Standort und dann starten
hier
die Flugzeuge heute morgen sind wie
gesagt so die ersten sieben acht
Maschinen in der Zeit zwischen 8 und 9
in die Luft gegangen
sie sind dann ins Einsatzgebiet geflogen
und es ist ja der erste Tag heute das
heißt von hier aus wurde der Luftraum
erstmal überprüft die Piloten mussten
sich an den Luftraum hier gewöhnen es
sind ja halt auch ausländische Piloten
dabei und in den nächsten Tagen wird es
dann von hier aus weitergehen
und aus welchen Ländern sind da denn
jetzt Piloten in Wunstorf
also hier in Wunstorf sind natürlich vor
allen Dingen viele Deutsche
Bundeswehrsoldaten stationiert insgesamt
ist es ein Standort der
2600 Menschen beherbergt und den einen
Arbeitsplatz bietet ungefähr 1500
Soldaten und Soldaten des
Lufttransportgeschwaders sind hier
stationiert und in den letzten Wochen
sind vor allen Dingen zahlreiche
Amerikaner gekommen das sind
amerikanische Reservisten ungefähr 600
Soldaten und Soldaten aus den USA sind
hier und momentan eine kleinere
Mannschaft aus Rumänien die mit einem
Flugzeug hier ist und das was die Männer
und Frauen jetzt hier in den kommenden
Tagen machen das erfahren sie halt im
Grunde genommen immer jeden Morgen aufs
Neue und dann werden die Einsatzplanung
besprochen und von hier aus geht's dann
in die Luft ist man muss sich das so
vorstellen dass diese Maschinen ja nicht
nur Material und auch Menschen
transportieren können sondern vor allen
Dingen für die Luftbetankung zuständig
sind das heißt
man geht von hier aus in die Luft Räume
über der Nord oder Ostsee beispielsweise
dort kommen dann die Jets an die
Eurofighter oder die Tornado Flugzeuge
wenn sie denn tankmäßig leer laufen und
dann werden sie wieder betankt damit sie
länger in der Luft bleiben können und
das findet hier mit den A400M der
Bundeswehr halt auch statt ungefähr
sieben bis acht Flugzeuge kann so ein
Airbus A400M dann betanken wenn er im
Einsatz ist
vielen Dank
ja ihr habt schon mitbekommen das ist
eine wahnsinnig große Übung und was
genau da passiert und wofür die gut ist
das hat Oliver dolker noch mal für uns
zusammengefasst
der Fliegerhorst Wunstorf in
Niedersachsen er ist das Drehkreuz der
größten luftlandeverlegeübung seit Ende
des Zweiten Weltkrieges 250 Flugzeuge
nehmen an der Übung eher Defender Teil
70 davon aus Deutschland die
Bereitstellung des Kerosins eine
logistische Herausforderung dafür wurde
in Wunstorf eigens ein mobiles
feldanklager errichtet meine Kompanie
ist hier seit der zweiten Kalenderwoche
also seit Anfang Januar 2023 hier im
Einsatz wir haben insgesamt 17.000
Tonnen Schotter bewegt knapp zwei
Kilometer an Rohrleitungen im Endeffekt
verlegt und sind jetzt in der Lage 2,4
Millionen Liter Kraftstoff also hier
Kerosin zu lagern das ist damit also
mehr in diesem mobilfunklage als in dem
Station
25 Nationen sowie die NATO üben den
Ernstfall das Szenario ein östliches
Militärbündnis ist in NATO Gebiet
eingedrungen und hält Ostdeutschland
besetzt geplant war die Übung die unter
deutscher Führung läuft lange vor dem
Krieg in der Ukraine
mit Erde Fender 2023 zeigen wir beweisen
wir und demonstrieren wir die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit dieses Bündnisses
diese Übung ist im Signal gegen
niemanden gerichtet es ist ein Signal an
uns an innengerichtet in die NATO hinein
sind überwiegend NATO-Staaten die an
dieser Übung teilnehmen die Deutsch
geführt ist dass wir in der Lage sind
dieses Land und dieses Bündnis zu
verteidigen viele Manöver werden in der
12 tägigen Übung trainiert von der
Luftbetankung bis zum Kampf gegen
Drohnen und Marschflugkörper ein
weiterer Punkt das Schützen von Städten
Flug und Seehäfen
wir wissen seit dem russischen Überfall
auf die Ukraine dass die europäische
Sicherheitsarchitektur so wie sie über
Jahrzehnte lang von uns unterstellt
worden ist eben nicht mehr funktioniert
und dass deswegen die Landesverteidigung
ganz zwingend eine wesentlich größere
Bedeutung haben muss durch die
zahlreichen militärflüge wird es enger
im deutschen Luftraum Einschränkungen im
zivilen Luftverkehr sind deshalb möglich
ja ihr habt ihn gerade schon im Beitrag
gesehen gleich sprechen wir auch mit dem
Inspekteur der Luftwaffe mit
generalleuten an Ingo Gerhards vorher
habe ich aber noch ein paar Fragen an
mein zdf-kollegen und
brüsselkorrespondenten Florian neuer
Hand hallo Florian schön dass du bei uns
bist ja hallo Grüße wir haben es ja
gerade gehört da wird simuliert dass
eine deutsche Großstadt angegriffen wird
von einem östlichen Militärbündnis
welche Signalwirkung geht gerade in
diesen Zeiten von dieser Übung aus
Florian
ich glaube das ist eine dreifache
Signalwirkung gibt und zwar einerseits
auch wenn das Herr Gerhards ja gerade
bestritten hat es ist ein Signal der
NATO-Staaten an Russland an Wladimir
Putin dass die NATO nämlich wie es hier
mal formuliert wird bereit ist und der
in der Lage ist jeden Zentimeter des
eigenen nato-gebietes zu verteidigen das
ist also die ganz klassische
Abschreckung eine Funktion der NATO die
wir noch aus den Zeiten des Kalten
Krieges kennen und die jetzt im
Angesicht dieses russischen Krieges
wieder wichtiger geworden ist das zweite
Signal ist sicherlich dass der deutschen
an die Nato-Partner das nämlich dass
Deutschland sagt wir sind bereit und
auch in der Lage da unsere Aufgabe zu
erfüllen da gab es ja durchaus Zweifel
an der Verteidigungsfähigkeit der
Bundeswehr Gelände gesagt auch durch
verschiedene Lücken und Mängel die bei
der Bundeswehr etwa man beim Puma
Debakel offensichtlich wurden da will
man jetzt zeigen dass Deutschland eben
bereit ist in der Lage ist auch da
seinen Beitrag zu leisten und dann noch
ein drittes Signal das über das hier
auch unter der Hand relativ offen
gesprochen wird dann diese Signal an die
deutsche Bevölkerung nämlich dass man
hier den deutschen klar macht das ist
ernst es ist nicht mehr nur ein Spiel es
ist wirklich eine Zeiten wenn die die
wir hier leben und ja dafür für die
Sicherstellung der eigenen Sicherheit
muss man wohl auch manche
Unannehmlichkeiten in Kauf nehmen
danke Florian erstmal für diese erste
Einschätzung wir sprechen uns gleich
noch mal und schauen jetzt aber noch mal
auf die Facts in figurs zu dieser Übung
die
Petra Riffel für uns zusammengefasst
trainiert werden die Verteidigung von
Städten Flughäfen und Häfen dabei soll
die Zusammenarbeit zwischen den 25
beteiligten Nationen und der NATO
optimiert werden unter der Führung der
deutschen Luft war für finden die
Übungen in drei Lufträumen über
Deutschland statt der Bereich Ost der
sich von Sachsen bis zur Ostsee
erstreckt der Bereich Süd der von Bayern
bis Rheinland-Pfalz reicht die meisten
der rund 200 täglichen Flüge wird es im
Bereich Nord geben weite Gebiete der
Nordsee gehören dazu geflogen wird in
einer Höhe von 2500 bis 15.000 Metern
Passagierflugzeuge fliegen im
Durchschnitt zwischen 9000 und 12.000
Metern
Ausnahme im Bereich Ost hier gibt es
tieflüge sogar unter 500 Metern hier
kann es sehr laut werden die Lufträume
sind täglich teilweise bis zu vier
Stunden für den zivilen Luftverkehr
gesperrt hier kommt es zu Verspätungen
und wahrscheinlich auch Flugausfällen
geflogen wird nur tagsüber
ja und über die Details und Hintergründe
dieser Übung spreche ich jetzt mit dem
Inspector der Luftwaffe ist und schon
zugeschaltet Generalleutnant Ingo
Gerhards hallo Herr Gerhardt
ja hallo
herr Gerhard wie läuft denn diese Übung
heute am ersten Tag an ist schon alles
in der Luft was in der Luft sein soll
ja wir haben heute den ersten Tag wie
sie schon sagten und das ist heute im
Wesentlichen ja eingewöhnungsflüge weil
wir sind 25 Nationen die teilweise aus
Ländern kommen wo wir über ganz andere
luftraumstrukturen verfügen so dass
dieser Tag eins alle in die Luft alles
nach einem Plan sie haben es ja auch
schon erwähnt es ist von Deutsch geführt
das heißt dieser Plan kommt von uns von
unserer Kommandozentrale am
niederrhein-wedem und dass das alles
funktioniert das alle den Plan bekommen
und dass wir zusammen in die Luft kommen
und zusammen auch wieder runter das üben
wir heute bis jetzt klappt alles absolut
reibungslos und was wir heute auch schon
als Besonderheit dabei haben einige
Kampfflugzeuge fliegen heute nach
Litauen werden dort landen bekommen dann
quasi Treibstoff tanken also wieder voll
und fliegen dann zurück um einfach
unseren östlichen Mitgliedschaft immer
wieder während der Übung klar zu machen
die sogenannte Rückversicherung auch ihr
seid natürlich Teil dieser NATO
wir haben auch schon angesprochen wie
groß diese Übung ist die wir da sehen
und es wird ja simuliert das Rostock von
einem östlichen Militärbündnis
angegriffen wird jetzt fragt sich
bestimmt einer oder eine die uns gerade
zuschauen hey warum den Rostock ist das
eine realistische Angst die man gerade
haben muss also warum der Zweck dieser
Übung
ja wir haben den den Luftraum ist nun
mal über über Nord- und Ostsee und
deswegen ist es nicht jetzt speziell nur
Rostock ist überhaupt die die Küste die
Ostseeküste die wir auf der einen Seite
der eine Teil unserer Übungsteilnehmer
eben simuliert angreift und die andere
Teil natürlich verteidigt und so ist es
aber auch in den anderen übungsgebieten
dass wir Städte schützen Hefe Flughäfen
das was wir als kritische Infrastruktur
bezeichnen ich würde jetzt nicht Rostock
alleine nicht als Stadt herausgreifen
sondern hier geht's mehr um die
Ostseeküste
es gab jetzt in letzter Zeit auch immer
wieder
gerade im
Ostsee russische Flugzeuge in den
europäischen Luftraum vorgedrungen sind
ist das denn jetzt eine Gefahr wenn wenn
so eine Übung gerade vorgeht das ist da
irgendwie zu Konfrontation kommt also
denkt man über sowas nachher
ja sie haben sie haben Recht wir hatten
das in den letzten Monaten verstärkt das
auch schon mal russische Flugzeuge
unserem eigenen Luftraum über der
Ostseeküste zu nahe kamen dann steigen
ja immer diese bewaffneten
Kampfflugzeuge die wir quasi 7 Tage die
Woche 365 Tage im Jahr auf 15 Minuten
Bereitschaft haben auf uns klar zu
machen bis hierhin und nicht weiter ich
denke nicht dass wir da jetzt verstärkt
mit diesen mit diesem Flügen der
russischen Kräfte zu rechnen haben weil
diese diese Übung ist in keinster Weise
auf Eskalation oder Aggression ausgelegt
wir machen keinerlei Flüge in Richtung
Kaliningrad aber wir haben nach wie vor
unsere sogenannten nato-alarm Orten so
nennen wir das also wir haben ein
mehreren Standorten in Deutschland
jeweils zwei Kampfflugzeuge voll
bewaffnet auf 15 Minuten Bereitschaft
stehen dass wenn sowas vorkommen würde
dann würden wir das auch so machen wie
wir das sonst im NATO Rahmen auch wie
wir sagen abarbeiten
ich habe ja gerade schon kurz mit meinem
zdf-kollegen Florian neuhahn in Brüssel
gesprochen der sieht in dieser Übung
schon eine Art Signalwirkung eine Art
Abschreckung der NATO die da Richtung
Russland geht würden sie den zustimmen
naja zuvor dass das erste Signal und ich
habe diese Übung ja 2018 erstmalig
vorgeschlagen in Amerika da war
natürlich das was uns alle schockiert
hat die Annexion der Grimm
völkerrechtswidrig sagte das ist nicht
akzeptabel dass wir schon klar machen
müssen
Landes- und bündnisverteilung a wir
können das und zum anderen das nahto
theoretum ist die rote Linie so das
Wesentliche Signal geht an uns selbst
auch an unsere Bevölkerung dass wir in
der Lage sind zu regieren und dass wir
das können ähm und ich würde jetzt nicht
speziell das Signal gegen Russland
senden aber es ist auch eins klar mit
dem Blick auf Russland es ist absolut
inakzeptabel dass man denkt in diesen
jetzigen Zeiten in Europa zu meinen
Grenze mit Gewalt zu verschieben
lassen Sie uns noch mal einen Blick auf
die explizit deutsche Luftwaffe sprechen
die sie ja einen Blick darauf werfen wie
sie ja verantworten wir haben das mit
einem Experten von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik gesprochen
haben Arnold der dazu folgendes gesagt
hat
diese Übung wurde bei längeren Zeitraum
geplant und demnach wurden auch die
Verfügbarkeiten von Luftfahrzeugen genau
auf diese Übung abgestimmt so dass man
mit einem hohen technischen Klarstand in
diese Übung starten kann grundsätzlich
können wir sagen dass in den letzten
Jahren einige Fortschritte erzielt
worden die klarsteine gerade im Bereich
unserer Eurofighter Flotte ist erheblich
gestiegen dort gab es Umstellung seitens
der Bundeswehr Anpassungen seitens der
Industrie und dadurch konnten dann mehr
Flieger einsatzbereit sein als wir die
Jahre davor erlebt haben natürlich bei
den älteren Maschinen bei dem Tornado
oder vielleicht auch bei unseren
Hubschraubern haben wir gesehen dass
natürlich aufgrund des Alters hier und
da mehrere Ausfälle immer wieder
hinzunehmen sind
im Prinzip sagt ist ja dass ich jetzt
für diese Übung sehr gut vorbereitet
wurde das auch in den letzten Jahren
diese flotten sich verbessert haben aber
das natürlich jetzt explizit auch auf
die Übung
hingearbeitet wurde was würden Sie denn
sagen ist die deutsche Luftwaffe aktuell
immer einsatzbereit oder liegt das jetzt
auch daran dass ich speziell für diese
Übung vorbereitet wurde
also was Herne da natürlich für einen
ein Bild skizziert ist genau dieses
differenzierte Bild das wir in Teilen
über hochmoderne Systeme verfügen die
auch mit einer hohen Einsatzbereitschaft
versehen sind Eurofighter als ich die
Luftwaffe 2018 übernommen habe hatten
wir gerade mal etwas über 30%
Einsatzbereitschaft wir liegen heute bei
80% und das liegen wir nicht nur weil
wir diese Übung fliegen sondern weil wir
das grundsätzlich so gestärkt haben aber
unsere älteren Waffensysteme jetzt z.B
das Waffensystem Tornado was wir jetzt
ja durch die R35 ersetzen und noch
weitere Eurofighter oder z.B
Hubschrauber durch den neuen
Hubschrauber den sogenannten schweren
Transporthubschrauber also man muss es
wirklich defensiert sehen in Teilen
haben wir schon sehr modernes Gerät und
teilen verfügen wir noch über Technik
veraltetes Gerät was natürlich jetzt in
den nächsten Jahren modernisiert werden
muss dafür ist ja letztlich auch der
Sondervermögen da
zum Sondervermögen kommen wir gleich
noch mal ich würde gerne noch mal über
das Personal sprechen das Gerät ist ja
die eine Herausforderung die sie auch
schon angesprochen haben das hat sich in
ihrer Laufbahn quasi schon stark
entwickelt wie sieht es denn aus mit der
Personalbesetzung gibt es da im
Ernstfall eigentlich genug Leute
also wir in der Luftwaffe wir haben
schon auf unserem Position top
ausgebildet ist ein gutes Personal und
ich bin ja heute hier in Wunstorf zu
Übungsbeginn da wo wir auch unseren
logistischen Drehscheibe haben und ich
habe heute schon mit vielen Amerikaner
gesprochen die war aber auch letzte
Frage Freitag in Norddeutschland in
Schleswig und den hohen und wenn ich mit
anderen Nationen spreche auch die
Nationen die in unserer Planung
beteiligt sind dann höre ich von den
Leuten was ihr für tolles Personal habt
ihr seid top ausgebildet also das ist
auch eigentlich ein starkes Statement
was wir auch mal nach vorne schieben
müssen dass wir eben gut ausgebildet ist
Personal haben dass unsere Leute
wirklich was können dass wir so eine
Übung auch organisieren können und wir
werden es in den nächsten Jahren das
wird aber das das wenn sie
gesellschaftlich schauen ist das ohne
Handy größte Herausforderung für alle
ausreichend Fachkräfte zu haben das
trifft uns natürlich genauso und da
werden wir die nächsten Jahre natürlich
immer hart dran arbeiten müssen
ja und jetzt noch Stichwort
Sondervermögen das hat ja letztes Jahr
in der politischen Debatte so ein
bisschen die von Scholz besprochene
Zeiten Wände eingeleitet wie kommen Sie
denn bei der Luftwaffe aktuell klar mit
diesem Sondervermögen reicht das große
Teile des Bedarf zu decken oder fehlt
das dann auch anders
also das Sondervermögen das ist viel
Geld und es ist auch gut wir müssen uns
auch sinnvoll nutzen und wir müssen
schnell nutzen aber man muss es als ich
sag's immer man muss das eine
Anschubfinanzierung sehen und es muss
natürlich die nächsten Jahre
entsprechend der jährliche Titel für die
Bundeswehr entsprechend mitwachsen so
dass wir dann auch über die Mittel haben
einmal das moderne Gerät was wir jetzt
über Sondervermögen beschaffen dann auch
betreiben zu können und z.B im Bereich
der der Bewaffnung der Munition haben
wir in Teilen auch in erhebliches
Defizit da müssen wir mehr davon kaufen
also quantitative Frage und da ist
natürlich nicht nur ausreichend das
Sondervermögen
danke hat bis hierhin wir haben noch
der Community die jetzt live
eingetrudelt sind die würde ich auch
noch mal an Sie richten und zwar fragt
Michaela Neubert auf YouTube wird es
vorkommen dass bei der Übung auch über
nicht geplante Gebiete in Deutschland
geflogen wird
noch mal die Frage das was für Gebiete
in Deutschland überflogen wird ob es
vorkommen wird das während der Übung
auch über aktuell nicht geplante Gebiete
geflogen wird also wird es da
Überraschungen geben nein
das ist eine klare Überraschung geben
okay dann haben sie noch eine Frage ich
habe noch eine Frage Entschuldigung wir
haben glaube ich eine leichte
Verzögerung hier fragt noch jemand auf
facebook weiß man den wie die Aktion von
Russland aktuell propagandistisch
begleitet wird es wird ja Putin enorm
viele Möglichkeiten diese Übungen
propagandistisch für sich
auszuschlachten
also ich denke mal aus aus deren Sicht
sehe ich jetzt nicht unbedingt das
Bestreben dass oder auch nicht unbedingt
die Möglichkeit dass das
propagandistisch auszuschlagen weil wir
natürlich zeigen zusammen wie schnell
und wie stark wir reagieren können und
ich ähm wir werden das natürlich
beobachten aber bis jetzt ist da noch
nicht zu erkennen
dann haben wir noch mal eine sehr
konkrete Frage zum Schluss auf Youtube
da fragt jemand wie viele einsatzfähige
deutsche Kampfflugzeuge haben wir
überhaupt
ähm also für verfügen die genaue Zeit
gar nicht so in die nennen aber für
verwöhnen über mehr als ausreichend also
wenn wir mal schauen bei den 250
Flugzeugen die bei dieser Übung
teilnehmen sind ungefähr 190
Kampfflugzeuge dabei die Amerikaner
Stellen mit mit ca 80 und wir stellen
damit ca 70 Flugzeuge dass die
zweitgrößte Kontingent personell sogar
mehr als die Hälfte also das zeigt schon
dass wir über eine hohe
Einsatzbereitschaft verfügen
Ingo Gerhardt der Inspektor der
Luftwaffe vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns
waren
und über die Bedeutung über die
Bedeutung dieser Übung für die NATO
spreche ich jetzt noch mal mit meinem
Kollegen Florian neuhahn in Brüssel der
uns jetzt zugeschaltet ist hallo Florian
hallo wir haben es ja gerade von Herrn
Gerhardt gehört der sagt so eine Übung
zeigt auch in Richtung Osten und zeigt
wie gut und schnell Nato-Partner und
weitere Verbündete zusammenarbeiten was
würdest du denn sagen wie schätzt du das
ein funktioniert dieser Verbund aktuell
schon gut hinsichtlich der Verteidigung
und wie notwendig ist diese Übung
aktuell
also im großen und ganzen funktioniert
die NATO es gibt sie ja auch seit jetzt
fast 75 Jahren da wird seit eben auch
dieser Zeit geübt aber das ist das große
aber es gibt natürlich die großen
Probleme zum einen kommen diese ganzen
Nationen auch zu dieser Übung eben mit
ganz verschiedenen Geräten an also es
gibt nicht den einen nato-standard es
gibt stattdessen verschiedene
Flugzeugsysteme es gibt verschiedene
panzersysteme es gibt sogar verschieden
Kaliber verschiedene Kaliber für die
Munition das alles muss erst einmal
koordiniert und abgestimmt werden also
die großen NATO Standards gibt es eben
nicht aber vielleicht noch wichtiger ist
ein zweites Problem dass ich auch bei
diversen Übungen erlebt habe die ich als
korint für das ZDF hier verfolgt habe
das ist nämlich die Kommunikation und
die Kultur der verschiedenen Armeen die
da aufeinander treffen also nur ein
Beispiel es gibt etwa die Armeen aus
Skandinavien wo die kleinsten Einheiten
sehr viel Entscheidungsfreiheit haben
eben sagen können was Sie als nächstes
machen weil sie das eben in ihrem
eigenen Umfeld am besten beurteilen
können und zum Kontrast gibt es eben
dann eine Armee wie aus den USA wo ein
General aus der Hauptstadt entscheidet
was mit den kleinsten Einheiten passiert
und wenn dann diese verschiedenen
Kulturen aufeinanderprallen dann gibt es
durchaus echte Kommunikationsprobleme
und die müssen eben gelöst werden weil
dann eben die eine arme etwas anderes
versteht als sie andere und dafür sind
solche Übungen eben sehr sehr wichtig
dass solche Kommunikations- und
kulturprobleme ausgeräumt werden denn
wenn ich übt der wird auch im Ernstfall
eben nicht bestehen
ein anderes Thema was wir gerade schon
kurz angesprochen haben ist diese
potenzielle Eskalation des Krieges durch
die Übung da gab es auch eine besorgte
Stimme aus der Community da sagt jemand
dieses kurzfristig geplante Manöver kann
dazu führen dass der Konflikt in der
Ukraine eskaliert und wir haben schon
angesprochen es gibt immer wieder
russische Flugzeuge im europäischen
Luftraum es gab schon einen
Zusammenprall einer US-Drohne mit einem
russischen Jet im März was glaubst Du
steigt jetzt die eskalationsgefahr durch
solch einen Manöver
also ich glaube speziell durch dieses
Manöver steigt sie nicht das ist ja auch
anders als hier die Kommentatorin gerade
geschrieben hatte oder gesagt hat eben
nicht kurzfristig geplant und
tatsächlich werden diese Manöver
langfristig bekannt gegeben auch über
interne Kanäle an Russland das heißt
alle umliegenden Länder die nicht der
NATO angehören sind eben informiert und
können sogar diese Übung auch beobachten
auch wird eben informiert darüber wo
genau geübt wird und was genau geübt
wird also eben das ist nur ein
defensives eine defensive Übung ist
natürlich es hat diese Vorfälle gegeben
diese Zwischenfälle die du gerade
erwähnt hast die Drohne über dem
Schwarzen Meer die diversen
Kampfjets der Russen die in NATO Gebiet
eingedrungen sind aber ich glaube es ist
auch im Interesse Russlands eine solche
Eskalation zwischen den beiden Blöcken
NATO und Russland jetzt zu vermeiden
insofern wird man da meines Erachtens
sehr sehr zurückhaltend sein und auf
solche kleinen Nadelstiche in dieser
Zeit sicherlich verzichten
wie guckt man denn in Brüssel aktuell
auf dieses Manöver was sind so Themen
zum Thema NATO die Brüssel gerade
bewegen
naja man schaut wie ich am Anfang
bereits sagte ja sehr genau darauf was
kann und was will Deutschland eigentlich
leisten und das wird hier schon sehr
honoriert dass es jetzt eine Übung gibt
wo Deutschland das in die Hand genommen
hat und eben der Welt und der NATO zeigt
dass dieses Land diese dort diese
deutsche Bundesregierung diese deutsche
Luftwaffe bereit ist und in der Lage ist
ihren Beitrag zur Verteidigung des
nato-gebietes zu leisten aber es gibt
ein Thema über das hier gerade auf NATO
Ebene sehr intensiv gestritten wird und
das ist die Frage der
Verteidigungsausgaben es gibt ja dieses
berühmte zwei Prozent Ziel bei den
Ausgaben für Verteidigung also zwei
Prozent des Bruttoinlandsproduktes eines
Landes soll für Verteidigung ausgegeben
werden und jetzt in vier Wochen beim
nächsten NATO-Gipfel soll ein neues Ziel
dafür geschaffen werden man will künftig
sagen die zwei Prozent sind der Boden
die untere Grenze nicht mehr das obere
Ziel
nun ist Deutschland eben von diesem Ziel
aber noch sehr weit entfernt es liegt
aktuell bei
1,49 Prozent also ein gutes halbes
Prozentpunkt entfernt und es gibt zwar
eine rhetorische Offenheit der
Bundesregierung für eine Verschärfung
eine höhere Ansetzung dieses zwei
Prozent Ziels aber de facto weil sie
keiner wie das erreicht werden soll weil
es ja gerade auch in Berlin heftige
Konflikte gibt über die Verwendung von
Mitteln und keiner sich vorstellen kann
woher dieses Geld kommen soll dass
Deutschland eben dieses 2% Ziel wirklich
kurzfristig erreichen wird
ja und Stichwort zwei Prozent Ziel was
jetzt das neue mindest Ziel werden soll
da zeigt sich ja auch schon ganz gut wer
in der NATO jetzt größere Anteile
übernimmt der kleinere Anteile übernimmt
und es ist seit jeher so dass die USA
den größten Teil der NATO finanzieren
und einnehmen da fragt man sich ja schon
wie gut kann denn Deutschland eigentlich
eine Luftwaffe im Alleingang oder eine
Luftverteidigung immer Alleingang
Leisten ist man wie abhängig ist man da
von diesem riesen Partner USA
also ich würde sagen man ist extrem
abhängig und dieses Manöver belegt das
auch wirklich eindrucksvolle Weise Herr
Gerhards der Luftwaffen Inspektor dass
er gerade noch mal erwähnt 180 Kampfjets
die an dieser Übung teilnehmen davon die
Hälfte 90 aus den USA das sind auch die
modernsten nämlich diese F35 Kampfjets
die Deutschland erst bis 2030 kaufen
wird also es gibt hier eine wirklich
extreme Abhängigkeit auf militärischer
Ebene von den USA den wichtigsten
Nato-Partner und diese Abhängigkeit
wirft natürlich fragen auch denn noch
haben wir eben einen US-Präsidenten
einen US-Regierung die sich sehr für
diese NATO interessiert und auch für die
Ukraine interessiert die USA sind mit
großem Abstand der wichtigste und größte
Waffenlieferant für die Ukraine aber im
nächsten Jahr zwei 24 eben haben wir in
den USA wieder Präsidentschaftswahlen
und da sind die Fragezeichen hier in
Brüssel und in vielen Hauptstädten
Europas doch sehr groß was wäre wenn da
eben wieder ein US-Präsident die Wahl
gewinnt der den NATO gegenüber sehr viel
kritische eingestellt ist also etwas
Donald Trump oder andere aus seiner
Partei und ich würde sagen eine echte
Antwort auf diese Frage hat man nicht
von echter europäischer Souveränität und
Autonomie jedenfalls kann man derzeit
keine Zeit sprechen
ja spannend dieser Punkt den du auch
gerade mit Ausblick auf das nächste Jahr
aufwirft vielen Dank Florian
ja und über das Weitergehen in dieser
Übung über die Entwicklung in der
Ukraine und sicher auch noch mal über
die Präsidentschaftswahl in den USA
darüber werden wir euch weiter hier bei
ZDF heute live informieren danke dass
ihr eingeschaltet habt danke dass ihr
Fragen und Kommentare geschrieben habt
und bis zum nächsten Mal